the Game Developers Conference otherwise
known as GDP it's taking place in San
Francisco from March seventeenth to the
21st it's a gathering for developers
where they share their knowledge about
the tools and techniques needed to make
the games you love to play GD c
celebrates the efforts of game
developers all around the world you were
such an inspiring community everyone
nominated tonight all of the games the
main competition games are what we do
and we do it because we love it if you
don't have a ticket to get to GDC this
year no worries gamespot will be
bringing you coverage of the show
throughout the week including some live
streams you just won't want to miss join
us live from GDC on Wednesday March 19th
at two p.m. pacific as former sega game
designer yu suzuki will be taking a look
back at Shenmue followed by a talk by
mega man creator Keiji Inafune a at 5pm
then at six-thirty you can see who takes
home the coveted Sheamus mcnally grand
prize in the IGF and GDC Awards on
Thursday Lucasfilm games will star in a
classic studio post mortem followed by
Shawn Robertson animation director of
irrational games will be on hand to talk
about creating Bioshock Infinite's
Elizabeth battlefield 4 level artist
linnea hair
then kicks off Friday to teach us how a
dice is creating a more dynamic
battlefield and last but not least ken
Levine of irrational games joins GDC to
talk about gaming narrative catch all
this and more live from GDC only on
gamespot